Take it off. TAKE IT OFF.
I agree that you were treated like you
were a toilet.
>> No, I agree. I do agree with you. Yes,
let me tell you why. Like a toilet, you
know why?
This little hijab from sisters, do your
qurbani with One Ummah, 100% donation
policy. 300 million people around the
world are starving, brothers and
sisters. I have my kids behind me. I
will do anything in my power as a
father, let alone a mother, to go and
feed them if I was to even think of them
being hungry. Just now, they were like,
"I'm hungry. Can you get me food?" As a
father to know that I have the ability
to give them food gives me some kind of
satisfaction that I am doing my purpose.
Imagine a father, if you're a father,
imagine a mother hearing their child,
"I'm hungry", and not being able to give
them. Wallahi, that will eat them up
alive. There are so many people out
there. Go to the link, guys, and you can
see, brothers and sisters, what they are
doing on the ground. Please donate for
the sake of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
even if it is £10, inshallah. May Allah
bless and honor and preserve you guys,
and you will see the rewards in the
hereafter. So, free far-right French
girls came to the UK to join the march,
and they were in a niqab in Tommy
Robinson's event, which was an absolute
failure. We was there on the day, and a
lot giving dawa to many of them who were
genuine British people had genuine
concerns. And subhanallah, brothers and
sisters, these individuals What was the
march about? What do you gain? His own
friends have boycotted him and said
they're not going to the march cuz what
is it? Just waving flags. Okay, what
What's the What's the ultimate goals?
What? Israelis funding it why? To cause
division, to blame Muslims for the real
problems that you guys have. So,
the march was an absolute flop. The
turnout was an absolute flop. Everything
about the event was an absolute flop.
These three girls who were coming in
niqab, and then you've got We're going
to show videos now of them
uh uh these um far-right uh protesters
uh screaming, okay, uh not every single
one of them far-right, but yeah,
screaming, "Get your
tits out. Get your tits out for the
lads."
This is what they've done to woman.
They've become mere sexual objects. And
guess what? I was speaking in the video
is on my Ali Dawah Road channel, two
girls that came to my table. And you
know what they said? They said, "Yeah,
no, you're right." There was another
fire individual there. Said, "No, yes,
it's true. We are treated crap like
sexual object." I'm saying that in the
Western world, the woman have been
sexualized to such a degree that you are
treated like you're a toilet.
>> No, I agree. I feel like I agree. Yes,
let me tell you why. Like a toilet, you
know why? Why Why Why do I feel like I
agree. I agree.
>> Yes, but but you know why?
>> like a toilet. But we are treated No.
Yes, but here's the video of these three
French girls who are in the club and
they're taking off. Let's have a look at
that.
>> [cheering]
>> Take it off. TAKE IT OFF. TAKE IT
[cheering]
>> SO, there you go, guys. You can see
clearly, yeah? Okay. I mean, this is
very interesting because if you go back
enough time, okay? I was speaking to a
lot of people from the protest.
Your ancestors will be turning in their
grave if they saw how you guys are
dressed up. Yes? If anything, you look
at the videos in the 1900s, your
great-grandparents, your parents
dressed up like Muslims. They had hijab.
Have you seen the video where they are
dressed up as hijab? If anything, they
would be at odds with you guys and what
you've become. Okay? That is what they
would have done, not the other way
around. Okay? And you saw the video of
them in the march asking, you know, "Get
your TITS out." Yeah? Because why?
They've reduced women to a mere sex
object. And these women are there
thinking like, "Yeah, I'm so liberated."
You know what I mean? Like I used to go
clubbing back in the day. And there'll
be girls like, "Yeah, I'm a HOE. I'm a
bad bitch." I don't know.
Like, why would you Can you imagine me
insulting myself? "I am a" Excuse my
language. "I am a BASTARD. r d. I am an
idiot. It's like you're cussing yourself
out. This is what conditioning does,
okay? It's called manufacturing consent
to the level they brainwash you, okay?
To the level that you accept it. Bikini,
bikini is something that is an underwear
that's been sold to you to be like, oh
no. What's the difference between an
underwear? There are women walking
around in their underwear and it has
been programmed. And when the first the
bikini came out, nobody wanted to wear
it. They were like, uh-uh-uh. That is so
scandalous. No.
But as time went, what did the Zionists
find and of course, what did they do?
Try to the make the woman degenerates,
okay?
So, the I the point here is what? It's
the Zionists that are in charge of the
Western media. Yes, and they've got the
money. Yes, making your woman
degenerates, making using your young
girls to send them to Epstein Islands to
blackmail the elite so they can go to
war in Iran, so we can pay £1.80 per
liter for diesel, okay? So, you saw the
video, it was an absolute the march was
an absolute failure. You saw also the
video of those two girls who were like,
you know what? Yes, we are treated like
sexual objects, okay? And that's why
there are so many Muslim so many women
coming to Islam. You know why? Because
they get liberated. They're not judged
based on their bodies, their backside,
here, there, their thighs or breasts or
whatever. They are treated like human
beings and Islam honors women. Yes, and
they control their sexuality by saying,
you are not going to judge me based on
my assets, but based on who I am. And
women in history like Maryam
al-Asturlabi who who made, learning from
her father, a the navigation system,
okay? Fatima al-Fihri, if I'm the first
university built in Morocco, okay? And
so many more women in history who have
offered society benefit, not a mere sex
object, working only fans, okay?
University student girls who are working
in strip clubs so they can pay for their
tuition fees.
This is the reality. And we Muslims want
what? We don't want If anyone's a
pervert. A pervert would want to see a
woman naked or covered? Naked. We as men
saying what? That you should cover up
because you know why? There are men out
there who are perverts. There are men
out there who want you for the wrong
things and they want to use you as
sexual objects and Islam has come to
honor the British woman because they are
our sisters and our daughters and our
mothers and we don't want them to be
used and abused like they're toilet.
Yes, men ejaculating inside them, excuse
me, and then going about their business.
Okay?
toilet. Why do you go to the toilet? To
relieve yourself. That's why
alhamdulillah the march was an absolute
flop. The dawah we did on the day was an
absolutely amazing alhamdulillah and we
spoke to many lovely people like these
two lovely ladies. May Allah subhana wa
ta'ala guide them to Islam and that's
what I wanted to bring to your
attention, guys. An absolute flop and
these three fridge niqabis,
what did you gain? Nothing. You just
showed what kind of idiotic morons you
guys are.
Till next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.